[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
hello and welcome everyone to EA play
20/20 we're happy that you're joining us
today
over the next 45 minutes or so we've got
so much for you including creative
innovative and really fun new games and
a lot of news to share but before we get
into the show I'd like to take just a
minute here I want to extend a heartfelt
thank you to first responders medical
staff and essential personnel this has
certainly been a challenging year from
natural disasters like the bush fires in
my home country to the devastating
covered 19 pandemic these brave heroes
are working to keep us safe and healthy
at every turn I also want to thank our
teams for their amazing dedication while
working from home what you've been able
to achieve is nothing short of
inspirational we were also deeply
thankful to all of you our players even
when we've had to stay physically apart
billions of you are using games to come
together to play and do amazing things
for each other
you've shown why this is truly the
greatest form of entertainment on the
planet this is also a critical time for
the movement and racism and racial
injustice in this world black lives
matter and there is much to be done to
drive real and meaningful change a
couple of weeks ago we shared some
actions that Electronic Arts is taking
we will not rest on this it's a long
term commitment we're here for players
of every color background religion and
personal preference we will continue to
build strong representation in our games
and we are focused on making our
communities fun inclusive and positive
places to play we also have real work to
do to bring greater diversity into our
company and we are committed to doing
that work today we're here because of
the power of games games bring us
together they can make our lives better
they can teach us they can provide
escape and self-expression
and most of all games can be fun all of
us Electronic Arts believe in that and
it's why we're excited to get up every
morning to make great experiences for
all of you so thanks for being here with
us and now let's get into some games
[Music]
what's up everybody I'm Greg Miller and
welcome to EA play we had an incredible
show in LA planned for you
huge stage massive set up these giant
monitors I was gonna fly in an x-wing I
was gonna land the x-wing on stage I was
gonna set off a bunch of fireworks then
what t-shirt came and bam shooting out
game consoles then Carol Baskins some
Tigers that last part was all me then
because of circumstances beyond our
control we had to come up with something
a little different instead of LA I'm in
my hometown of San Francisco but we
still have the Tigers what's that you
know tires so you like oh all right I'm
being told there are no Tigers but
whatever we're still gonna bring you the
EA play you know and love-- huge
surprises big announcements incredible
reveals and never-before-seen gameplay
coming up over the next hour we've got
game reveals galore world premiere
trailers of new titles some old
favorites making a comeback a look at a
new way Star Wars fans can live out
their greatest fantasies this year plus
a sneak peek at the future oh and pay
close attention because today you could
win one of thousands of steam codes for
more than a dozen great EA games on
Steam throughout the show keep an eye
out for discreetly placed golden letters
write them down as they appear and at
the end of the show we'll tell you where
you can enter that secret code for a
chance to win free games on Steam so
don't go anywhere
Who am I kidding none of us can leave
our houses but enough talking let's see
some games up first we're headed to the
Outlands that's right it's apex legends
time
anyone want to take me out
[Music]
you should smile
hey pics fans the battle just keeps
getting bigger thanks to you
apex legends is coming off its most
successful most epic season yet and
we're just getting started season four
saw more of you jumping into the fight
than ever before and you've kept that
amazing momentum going forward making
season 5 the biggest and best start to a
season ever hold on to your Holograms we
hope you've been enjoying season 5
fortunes favor which has seen the
introduction of our latest legend lobha
a major map change to Kings Canyon
rest in peace skull town an all-new
ranked series and a ton of quality of
life updates but it's about to get even
better today I'm here to tell you about
what's coming next - season 5 with our
latest collection event lost treasures
take a look
adventurous Raiders explorers they risk
everything in such a fame fortune and
answers if you find what they're looking
for but if they survive they might walk
away with lost treasures Oh high five
you all when I see you
mobile-responsive in here
wreck yourself Thanks
guns who needs guns I don't need guns
I know what I'm looking for I won't walk
away without donuts Hezekiah
as you just saw the lost treasures
collection event brings with it a ton of
great content including a new limited
time mode armed and dangerous' evolved
it's the return of a fan-favorite
snipers and shot he's only but with a
twist
sending out my decoy all armor is evil
armor and we're removing all of the
respawn beacons across the entire map
don't worry though you'll still be able
to bring back your teammates with the
help of a new item the mobile respawn
Deacon you'll have one of these in your
inventory at the start of each match
giving you the power to choose win and
more importantly where you bring your
teammates back into the battle lost
treasures also introduces the new town
takeover cryptos map ring which gives
players a closer look at what motivates
this drone wielding hacker
and of course the lost treasures
collection delivers a bunch of exclusive
content you can earn by completing
challenges as well as all new event
exclusive cosmetic items and the
introduction of you boy mirages heirloom
which is fittingly a trophy of himself
excited to see you all on the ring don't
worry there's plenty of bees to go
around
crown and the best part is you don't
have to wait that long
lost treasures drops on Tuesday June
23rd and that's not all apex fans the
battle is expanding that's right this
fall we're bringing apex legends to
steam and I know you're hoping wondering
praying so before you ask yeah cross
play is coming to apex this fall it's
been one of the biggest requests we get
and we're thrilled to finally deliver it
to our fans what am I forgetting
oh yeah one last thing let's make it
official we're huge fans of Nintendo
here at respawn and we're incredibly
excited to be bringing apex legends to
the switch this fall and we'll share
more details in the months ahead so that
means you'll be able to squad up no
matter where are you and your friends
prefer to play xbox playstation switch
or on the PC via Origen and steam we're
throwing out a lifeline and healing the
divide between the platforms on behalf
of the entire apex team we want to thank
our incredible community your passion
for the game is truly inspiring we look
forward to seeing you all in the arena
and don't forget check out lost
treasures on June 23rd
whoa huh man how is it made I think a
fiber but hyperbola I think I'm
hyperventilating here
Sol Sol everyone one thing I admire
about apex legends is its commitment to
having such a diverse range of
characters at the Sims we've always
believed representation and diversity in
games is critically important perhaps
now more than ever it's difficult to put
into words just how meaningful it can be
to see yourself reflected in the games
you play so here to tell you in their
own words are a few members of our Sims
community it's a very interesting thing
to explain it feels empowering actually
and very moving it really taught me
alive the importance of just like
keeping relationships good with people
it's probably like the only place where
I was open they get to see my
personality first before seeing my
disability I guess you could say I found
myself to be the only black child in my
school I was discriminated I was bullied
my skin tone my height and my teeth
first realized that I was trans and I
had I was like praying to God to undo it
I have this world where I can express
myself and be myself where I come from
Who I am the color my skin you know who
I'm attracted to let any of that get in
the way it was it was no barriers no
matter where I was or what I was going
through I had my safe place this is
plausible this is a future you can have
was almost like I was peeking into the
future and I didn't know it at the time
but it gave me hope it gave me a sense
of hope that I could build a life that
looked like that
The Sims is almost like a utopia of what
I hope our world eventually becomes as I
got more comfortable with my character
in the game I got more comfortable with
myself I play to build me I play to
express myself I play to make a
difference a play to feel good about
myself I play to have confidence to have
fuel my creativity it's more than just a
game it's creating your life
as you just saw there are so many
reasons why I am proud to be part of the
Sims global community we want the Sims
to be a place of unity and hope a place
where you can be your authentic self and
build your vision for our shared world a
place to imagine what's possible to our
simmers thank you for everything you've
done to make your communities virtual
and real a better place
now I know some of you tuned in hoping
for some Sims news and we'll have plenty
to share as the summer goes on but we do
have one announcement for you we'll be
welcoming players on a whole new
platform as the sims 4 arrives on Steam
today take a look
[Music]
and creatures are plenty
[Music]
we particle clarity
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
everyone Alex here from the social team
and joining me today from our community
team is Freeman hi folks yes we're here
to tell you that it's not just the Sims
for arriving on Steam today five more
great EA games including titanfall 2 a
way out and dead space free at all
playable right this second in when EA
access arrives on Steam this fall you
can get all those great titles and a ton
more with your membership you can also
expect to see our new releases on Steam
- one of the first arrive just a short
while ago with full mod support via
Steamworks the critics love it and we
know you will - this is command &
Conquer remastered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back commander and steam isn't
the only platform getting some love
we'll be bringing games to more
platforms than ever you can expect seven
new games coming to switch in the next
12 months including burnout paradise
coming tomorrow and apex legends later
this year and we're bringing cross-play
to many of your favorite games -
starting with Need for Speed Heat and
continuing with some new titles being
revealed later in the show it's all
about giving you the freedom to play
what you want where you want and with
who you want it's about playing together
absolutely
now let's reveal some more games over to
you Greg quick reminder to keep an eye
out for those special golden letters
hidden throughout the show they could
appear anywhere and I mean anywhere so
keep your eyes open write the letters
down as they appear and once you've got
the full code you'll be able to enter
for a chance to win one of more than a
dozen great games on Steam so stay tuned
and find out where to enter the code at
the end of the show now if you follow my
content at all then you know there's
nothing I love more than buffalo wings
and discovering inventive new games well
I don't have any buffalo wings but I do
have something just as tasty over the
past couple of years
EA is partnered with the amazing Studios
like haze light and zoink to give us
such creative titles as a way out in
faith here to explain how they do it are
a few of the talented developers working
on the next wave of EA originals
sometimes you just have this great idea
of a game but it can be really hard to
do it on your own we wanted space for
our Studios creativity can flow free so
that we can try unconventional
approaches to solving new ideas there
are times where you've gotta like break
past your own sort of mental blocks even
if that meant building a whole new kind
of game engine we get to do the game we
want to do nothing and I mean nothing
comes into the game if it doesn't follow
the vision we can really push our ideas
further and bigger than we first
imagined let's find that magic
[Music]
and now for a deeper dive into what
these developers are working on we turn
our spotlight on three studios a first
is haze light in their mild mannered
quiet leader Joseph Faris let's do it
please welcome
Joseph fair as there are like passionate
people that are crazy people there's me
[Music]
okay can you swear here kiss Tuskers you
know knock polish is there a yeah I know
I'm coffee I can't help it man
I was born in Beirut 1977
I lived there 10 years it was civil war
and there was a lot of bad stuff
happening there
we tried to move five times to Sweden
the fifth time they let us in and that's
like if just wheelin cuz I've given
Sweden a lot you know my third movies
those are is basically about my life
when I came to Sweden when I was young
I've done five fishing movies and I've
done three games and it's way hard to
make a game it's almost like the
audience have controlled of the pacing
on the story while the movies is being
paced for you in video games there's so
much to be explored from a storytelling
perspective because of the interactivity
there are some students out there that
are making into have good stories but
they pretty much have one mechanic like
Yuri use all the time
designers and the story writers are kind
of like doing two different games that's
why I founded his life to keep pushing
the boundaries of what is possible in
games
that's what game number three from his
life is all about the new game it takes
two is a co-op action-adventure
platformer that would blow your mind
away the story starts out with a small
family Cody may that's the parents and
then grows the little daughters so
Colleen may about separate Rose doesn't
want to be divorced
- she creates two dogs on a wood and
clay and these dogs magically come alive
and actually controls both Cody and May
and you could say you're almost
controlling their emotions your own all
of us playing in their emotions there's
even levels where we're actually making
a mechanic for their emotions so again
marrying the story and the mechanics and
I think for the players that's gonna
feel very new different and unique they
haven't played anything like this before
it takes - is that crazy rollercoaster
ride that doesn't really have an enemy
it has an ending but
and is that the roller coaster crashes
and you fly into the sky get up into
space and when you're his crazy like
what am i doing up here and then maybe
you get back to to earth again it's not
the best way to describe that it takes
to actually
Wow that was that was the best way to
describe it all right Joseph we love you
so much thank you keep it up over there
the Oscars of course ladies and
gentlemen let's keep this originals
train rolling and let's stay in Sweden
for some a fan of both their delicious
red gummy fish and their video games so
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Klaus and Olaf from joint games thanks
Greg
welcome to Gothenburg and we'll buy home
unfortunately I didn't bring you any
swedish fish but we do have some
exciting news for you about our latest
game at sewing we've always been driven
by love of rich visual storytelling and
creating strange worlds that people can
escape to the weirder the better and I
think my friend Olaf would agree yeah
absolutely
and for our next game though we wanted
to try something a little darker
something out of a gothic fairy tale but
started with a mood and some painting
screw into this eerie strange world that
feels like something out of a beautiful
twisted dream and that's the world of
random lost and random is the story of
even a little girl with a big heart and
an even bigger temper after a horrible
event the changes of life she embarks on
a dangerous journey through the world
random but fortunately she's not alone
just like I have below even also has a
crazy little weird friend thing with her
along her journey even discovers dicey
a playful loyal almost puppy like dice
companion that gives her the power to
really change things in the kingdom of
random
despite the name an even swirled
randomness is feared and the dark force
controls every aspect of life from where
you live to how you act or what your
favorite color is it's a coming-of-age
story set against the backdrop of the
mysterious world but it holds a modern
message that's really relevant to our
world right now I think we can all
relate to the desire to try and control
the chaos around us with Dicey's help
though human learns the power in doing
just the opposite
embrace the randomness accept
uncertainties in life and you'll be
surprised how far it takes you imagine
if you could change the course of life
with a roll of a dice what would you do
play it safe or trust in yourself and
take a chance we can't wait for you to
play and find out we're still a long
ways from launch but we hope you will
join even and dicey on the journey next
year until then please enjoy this first
look at lost and random will come to
random
the world of random bends with the role
of one guys a die set is rule this
kingdom for generations transforming the
fates of people just like you but what
if I told you there is another dice with
the power to change everything now my
friend it's your turn to roll to play
the odds and break the curse of random
[Music]
you can't have the sweet without the
sour
I know dicey they should be scared of us
right
[Music]
really cool that's a look at lost in
random in man embracing randomness I
feel like I live that every day of my
life you know is gonna do that you
didn't know that die seize my spirit
animal the games out next year but for
something that's blasting off a whole
lot sooner
take it away Kevin Franklin final strike
games our team of experienced industry
veterans have worked on incredible
multiplier franchises we are
passionately focused on making great
multiplayer games that's why I am
incredibly excited to announce that we
have partnered with the talented team
and EA to release our first ever title
rocket arena as you'll see we stay loyal
to the name of the game
it's a rockets only shooter that allows
players to get into the action quickly
and stay in the fight we want a rocket
arena to be an awesome competitive
experience to play with friends I think
you're gonna love what we've got in
store for you here is the all-new
trailer of rocket arena enjoy rockets
away
in a year the trophy will soon be mine
[Music]
have you ever wondered why life is so
good on crater sure we've got the
beautiful beaches quality public
transportation and exotic destinations
the people are courteous and friendly
always happy their fellowship are you
leaving but the real reason life is so
good we've got rocket
[Music]
betrayal
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
turn your back on the water
[Music]
I'm here to rock it
I'm having a blast
so as you just saw rockets are obviously
awesome to blast all over the place but
in order to come out on top there's a
lot to master you'll have a range of
rocket-powered abilities to blast
opponents out of the arena and an
arsenal of evasive moves rocket jump
rocket climb and dodge to avoid getting
knocked out yourself
don't worry though you're never out of
the action for long even when you're out
you'll fly right back into the fray
you'll also be able to really customize
your own unique look and play style each
of the 10 year is available at launch
have their own rocket-powered abilities
and as you play you'll discover items
that allow you to further refine each of
your heroes play styles Plus every
character has a hundred levels of
progression that unlock new cosmetics
and rewards all that and much more when
rocket arena arrives on July 14th and
there's plenty more content to come in
our first season which begins just two
weeks after launch on July 28th and
brings with it a blast pass and a ton of
free content including new maps in game
events and a new playable character
rocket arena is a game meant to be
played with friends regardless of
platform that's why we're thrilled to
announce cross play support right from
the start
so grab your friends regardless of their
platform and get ready to blast off with
rocket arena on July 14th on PlayStation
Xbox origin and steam and we'll be
sharing more gameplay right after the
show with the help of some great content
creators so check us out on youtube at
the link below see you in the arena wow
that looks great and hopefully you've
all been keeping track of the golden
letters hidden throughout the show and
nearly crack the code here's a hint
it's not Kanye keep an eye out for the
last couple of letters and then at the
end of the show we'll reveal where you
need to go to enter the code and a
chance to win some great games on Steam
now from the future of rocket warfare we
head to a different kind of battle it's
the real reason I didn't get any sleep
last night
and if you thought you heard sleigh
bells that's because it might as well be
Christmas in June it's finally time to
talk Star Wars
squadrons ok I promise you we are gonna
get a first look at some brand new
gameplay in just a moment but first for
anyone who doesn't fully grasp why I'm
so excited
earlier this week EA and Lucasfilm
dropped a trailer that literally gave me
all the fields chills joy excitement and
then more chills on top of that take a
look
[Music]
[Music]
use that moment
when the perfect shot
makes history
five pilots one squadron the galaxy's
finest
[Music]
Wow the eight-year-old and all of us is
celebrating and excited the 37 year old
man on this couch is excited ladies and
gentlemen for the second year in a row I
have the honor and privilege of helping
introduce a new Star Wars title and here
to put the hype in hyperdrive is none
other than motives creative director Ian
Frazer hello Ian hey Greg how you doing
I'm great how are you doing good happy
to actually get to show this to people I
bet now in my copious notes I have on
you I'm told you are quite the star wars
fan have been a long time how long do
you like Star Wars I've been the star
wars fan for pretty much my whole life I
don't even remember the first time I saw
the movies and as a kid there was a lot
of different parts of Star Wars I loved
one of them was being a pilot that idea
of climbing into an x-wing or a TIE
fighter so you know I played all the
flight games in the 90s and I got pretty
obsessive about them I'd pause
meticulously draw the insides of the
cockpits and stuff and actually I dug up
some of those drawings for my parents
attic over the holidays we're showing
them right now to the world this strikes
me as above and beyond the normal level
of Star Wars fandom I think it motive
lined that quite a few people have that
level of Star Wars fandom we started
this project I talked to a lot of people
as they joined the team and a lot of
them had similar kinds of stories of
things they'd done as kids one of them
even built a functional cockpit in his
garage that's another level how do you
guys go from being a fan drawing what
you see in the game we're building a
cockpit in your garage it's actually
making this game
well I think that fandom just love of
Star Wars has provided a really good
foundation for us but on top of that of
course the team at mode have got a lot
of experience working with Star Wars
when they worked on battlefront 2 and
when battlefront too wrapped up there
was a really small group of us that were
really into particularly the pilot
experienced in Star Wars and we wanted
to make something new something that
really went all-in on that part of the
fantasy and so we did kind of a
grassroots initiative our started a
little passion project and that ramped
up into eventually what is the game
we're gonna show you today you talk
about you know your passion for this
your nostalgia for Star Wars flight
games of the past how do you honor that
but make something brand new it's been
interesting you know we're
to kind of pull from that spiritual
heritage of many different games in that
time period at the same time we want to
do something that feels fresh and new
for fans today and so we've tried to
look at is sort of the spiritual core of
what I think are the best of the Star
Wars flight games of the past and what
they did that I love is that they made
that part of the universe real the level
of depth and detail that they show in
the ships of the way that you control
them is something that I remember fondly
from my childhood and it's something
that we're trying to do very much with
squadrons you know in real life being a
pilot is hard it takes skill and that's
something that you'll see throughout the
game you know as you start off playing
it's pretty straightforward fly around
shoot your lasers but as you get deeper
into it you start learning how to divert
energy from your lasers to your to your
engines how to shift your shields from
the front to the back to cover your butt
in a dogfight or at the higher levels of
skill you could do really crazy stuff
like you can boost your engines fly
ahead cut them off whip around 180 and
shoot a missile off your own tail while
drifting backwards like real ace pilot
stuff and that's that's really where we
have a lot of fun with the game I want
to do that I want to learn too that I
understand the nuts and bolts of how to
play it is there a single-player story
is there a multiplayer mode what are we
getting into it's actually some of both
so the game starts with a brand new
single-player story takes place a little
bit after Return of the Jedi and it has
kind of a unique dual perspective
approach to it so when the game starts
you're going to create two pilots you
create a new Republic pilot and an
imperial pilot and you're gonna
alternate between their perspectives
mission the mission over the course of
the story you're gonna meet a diverse
cast of characters along the way and
also a few familiar faces now when
you're done with that story and you've
played maybe a bit in the practice range
you say hey I want to try multiplayer we
want to make it really easy for you to
hop online with your friends and play
competitive space battles at that point
and so we've done a lot to try to reduce
the barriers to make it as easy as
possible for you to play with your
friends and so I'm happy to say we fully
support cross play you could be on ps4
Xbox one PC you could be playing on a
traditional display or in VR which fun
fact the entire game supports VR from
beginning to end pretty cool but
regardless of how you're playing which
platform they can all play together just
hook up with your friend connect have an
awesome space pal you just discard my
mind man like I don't that's
awesome that is the big question when
can people actually play it ah not too
long actually start where squadrons is
coming out on October 2nd okay okay not
too long at all I was worried about you
I thought you'd leave me on a teaser
there you didn't actually deliver it I
appreciate that
the next big ask I have on behalf of
everybody watching I'm sure who came
here for one specific reason can we see
some new gameplay of it can we see any
gameplay of it absolutely I kind of
figured you might want to on behalf of
everyone at motive and the team at
Lucasfilm I am very happy to show you
the worlds first look at gameplay of
Star Wars squadrons enjoy
[Music]
second Death Star's call but the
Imperial bleach is still a threat
Vanguard squadron let's make history
this is it Titan squadron everything
we've done has led to this finish those
bad guards stop this is Star Wars
squadron earn your wings in a
single-player story spanning two
factions all stations and master
multiplayer battles as a squadron of
five with the option to play the entire
game in VR this is the definitive Star
Wars pilot experience
[Music]
you'll begin your career in a
single-player story
welcome to titan squadron where you'll
play as two combat pilots flying for
both the Empire and the New Republic
you'll experience this world through
your cockpit the instrumentation in
front of you provides critical feedback
about power management targeting and
shields with a squadron of diverse
characters at your side prove your
skills on increasingly challenging
missions
welcome to the nadir Dockyard one of my
spies has leaked the attacks with the
New Republic star Hawk project the story
of the two pilots you playing stick
together and we'll shoot the balance of
power in the galaxy to take the fight
online you'll need flight time with all
eight ship's fighters are the most
flexible and versatile able to handle
any situation
interceptors are fast and highly
maneuverable let's get a ideal for
hunting down your opponent's star
fighters support ships can keep allies
safe and stocked up as well as
disrupting enemy fighters bombers are
the heavy hitters able to deal
devastating damage to enemy flag ships
and star fighters if you've got a
preferred component you need something
customized I'll take care of you unlock
everything you need to customize your
pilot and star fighters simply by
playing the game from cosmetics to an
arsenal of over 50 components that alter
how your ships fly bite and survive
I'll deal with it you can dramatically
change your loadout depending on your
squadron strategy finally Gotham this
will be critical in Star Wars squadrons
multiplayer modes first up dogfights
this is an all-out 5v5 fine-tune your
load outs to work as a team moving in on
the enemy utilize components like
tractor beams turrets and mines to slow
down your opponent's or set up your
squad mates for the kill
four teams looking for an even greater
challenge it's time to prove yourself in
Star Wars squadrons signature Mon fleet
balanced fleet battles are multistage
conflicts whether playing solos or with
friends options compete against other
players or AI as a squadron of five
don't worry I got it for you meet your
team in the social hub to solidify a
strategy coordinate loadouts and prepare
for takeoff
first push the frontline by winning the
dogfight in the center of the map next
attack or defend to medium-sized capital
ships
we've lost our capital ships and finally
the ultimate goal target and destroy the
subsystems of your opponent's massive
flagship and take it down at each phase
your squadron either pushes the line
forward or falls back to defense keep
our flagship safe is your squadrons
choice of how to play stay together
strike quickly stealth and subversion we
need to hurry
a unified squadron is the key to victory
this is star wars squadrons join the
galaxy's finest and make your margin
you other hope miss galaxy
[Music]
what's up everyone its super Lamar
Jackson I'm excited to be a part of the
s4 his family it should be you guys new
man cover athlete I can't wait so you
guys what we have stuff in a season this
is EA Sports next it's like I'm like
I'm not saying don't say that you see
[Applause]
it's just me and to keep it your hardest
like
[Music]
scored a goal
and your hero at history coffee name you
know what it sounds like 60,000 people
singing awesome football my heart feel
it in comes AC see the unknown I want
the real see
I want nap sweat for me since picking
hair-raising I want to live in the flow
birds
I want to feel it all a sport to make a
[Music]
now that's a lot to look forward to but
there's more here to tell us about the
future of gaming is EA's chief studio
officer Laura Miele thanks grey and
thanks Lamar
welcome to the EA Sports family there
are great things to come from EA Sports
for all of you and that's just the
beginning as you've seen throughout the
show today our electronic artists are
working hard to bring you more of the
games that you want to play games like
Star Wars squadrons apex legends and
command & Conquer these games all exist
because of you your voices are heard and
we are acting on your feedback now we've
talked a lot about all the exciting
games you'll be playing this year but
our studios are working even further out
creating new experiences new stories new
gameplay all enabled by new console
technology and we're so excited that was
to come we don't want to wait until next
June to share what the teams are working
on
generation shifts are an opportunity to
push beyond the boundaries of gaming as
we know it today and this time is no
different our studios are taking their
crazy ambitious ideas and making them
real criterion is known for how their
games feel from superior physics to
nuanced details of gameplay this team
hand curates the moment-to-moment
experience and with the new consoles
this year there will be a seamless
immersion which will get you into the
race in a matter of seconds
Bioware imagines and creates worlds
where you become the hero of your own
story and we're using this next
generation of technology to make those
fantasy worlds your reality for every
console generation dice sets the bar for
excellence in audio and visual
presentation we are creating epic
battles at a scale and fidelity unlike
anything you've experienced before that
motive we are working on a highly
ambitious and innovative new game that
puts the power and creativity in your
hands and it's the experience that would
have been impossible without next-gen
technology
[Music]
this is just the beginning of the things
we are working on and there is so much
more to come the future of EA Studios is
not just about new technology it's about
you your voices your ideas we want to be
where you come to play we want to make
games for everyone so please keep giving
us your feedback and let's build the
future together
on behalf of all of our studios thank
you for joining us today but before we
sign off there's just one more game
we would love to share cousin Darrin
over to you thank you so the moment is
here we finally get to say we're doing
it skates happening we're rolling we've
secretly got together
it's the beginning the skate evolution
continues we've been waiting years
honestly to to make the right game at
the right time with the right idea and
really really pleased to say that we're
here it is really early but it takes a
little while to flank us or wake them up
dude harsh still we've got a long way to
go but we're stoked and this is just the
beginning and seriously we we really
can't wait to bring you guys in and have
you be a part of it with us we want to
thank you for your passion your patience
and all the support that you've shown
you know us to get to this point in the
comments it's it's amazing we cannot
believe you commented this into
existence amazing
skate changed my life thank you so much
escape forever guys guys we did it we
brought back skate thank you to EA thank
you to coz thank you - Darren thank you
to you thank you to me I can't believe
that I'm so happy in my heart rate is
this what exercise feels like ladies and
gentlemen I can't believe it before we
go because I love you guys
here are the last letters of the secret
code if you think you've got the
complete code go to play or not GG / EA
and enter for a chance to win one of
thousands of free games sponsored by
player GG you can find the official
rules and everything else over at player
GG
II a now this has been in an amazing
experience an amazing opportunity for
all of us all over the world to come
together and celebrate gaming thank you
for being part of EA play until next
time I'll see you online and it's been
my pleasure to serve you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm sad but you know some very cool
reveals that a brand new skate cross
play seemed to be the word de jour
but let's go in-depth and talk about EA
play I'm Lucie joined by Michael hi I'm
oh and tomorrow saying I know I'm so
sorry we really wanted to see some Mass
Effect I think that was a little hinted
Dragon Age but let's go through the
press conference and talk about the
games that were shown off today so I
mean let's also talk a little bit about
Andrew Wilson's comment at the beginning
I'm very glad that they addressed the
black lives matter movement as well as
you know their ongoing commitments
during the EA work force as well as
saying thank you to health care workers
I think it's very important for them to
do run and Michael what did you think
yeah I I think it's it's pretty much a
necessity for any company who's gonna be
you know front-facing during this time
is to say something I mean we could have
a conversation about like how that turns
out in action but you know it's I think
that there's a statement at least across
the board covered covered those swath of
things that are happening in our world
but you know of course actions speak
louder than words so moving forward you
know I want to like like any other
company who's like saying things like
this I would take their word for it but
I also want to see how that affects what
they do forward and you know at least
from what we've seen in the throughout
this EE a conference is like you know
we're starting to see a lot more
diversity as a standard across like
character representation and also like
people who make games so yeah I'm
excited to see what that has in store
for the future as well so that was the
love us from the start of the conference
and then the first game that we saw a
lot of was apex legends so June 23rd
we're gonna get a brand-new limited time
mode I'm gonna throw it to you Michael
ganks I know you're big a boy mm-hmm so
I actually got to talk to Trey Grenier
beforehand so I kept kept my mouth shut
during the pre-show but now I think
either now or a little bit later you can
see
interview with Chad Grenier and at least
after this livestream don't go no right
now but we talked about the swath of
things that are coming to Apex legends
and like I said in the pre-show apex
legends is going ham and they don't stop
so season 5 was obviously big with Lobo
and stuff but introducing lost treasures
collection event channeling that that
energy from the previous was at the arms
and dangerous event which is shotguns
and sniper bringing that back tweaking a
few things very exciting that's coming
next week limited time mode and the
respawn beacon stuff is actually pretty
interesting when you actually get to
play with it
so that that's gonna that's gonna be
pretty fun but as far as the big things
go boy come to switch I know I asked
Chad Grenier a little bit about if you
can get to the technical stuff but they
have nothing to say quite yet in terms
of like target resolution target FPS
performance UI elements that's all stuff
that we're gonna see it down the line
but I'm impressed they're even doing it
at all just because of how huge apex is
and it's going to I think something they
didn't touch on in the presser but I did
get information from him is that there's
gonna be gyroscope motion control aiming
which i think is really important
because if you're gonna play in handheld
mode joy Khan's are trash for aiming so
I think that's very important especially
because they're gonna have cross play so
if you're on switch steam origin that's
another thing that it's coming to steam
that's wild all bunch of yay games to
come to steam it's gonna be cross play
oh we've been asking this for so long
and it's finally gonna happen
it's kind of an initiative across the
board with EA which is really cool with
a bunch of their games but put a like
cross the board playing apex I love
playing on PC but I know bunch of my
homies play on ps4 I wanna play with
them so this is gonna be it's gonna be
it's gonna be dope I you know apex
legends keeps delivering and I'm excited
to play with more people down the line
with because I think Ross plays coming
in fall and also the switch versions
coming in fall so those things will come
out right now exciting limited-time
events but man future's bright for apex
yeah it is I mean the one thing I will
say if a cross play is that I hope they
take the precaution that if people are
playing on mouse and keyboard they're
not paired up against people who are on
controller like if you're playing on
controller
through PC that's all well and good but
you can't deny that mouse and keyboard
is well I don't know because it's like
the toss-up right because you get the
auto aim coming through on it so I
assume they're gonna be working on that
term this is not an apples to apples
comparison by any means but it's
interesting that Michael mentioned the
gyroscope controls because Tom when you
played overwatch on switch how did that
work for you for a first-person shooter
I mean it was fine it was it was not
comfortable like the the jitteriness
that comes with gyroscopic gaming is a
big factor for me and you don't have a
lot of that on console or mouse and
keyboard but it's very functional I feel
like if you want to play a quick game of
Apex the switch has enough options in
terms of control mechanisms to make that
happen
I expect the like overwatch the
gyroscopic stuff might be a bit of a
curio that people try for a bit or it
could work out that it specifically
works really well for certain characters
like I found when I was playing with
gyroscopes aiming in overwatch that some
characters like soldier and that kind of
stuff wasn't great for it because I
wanted refined aim and control myself
but there were some characters that were
pretty good to do it with like Winston
just jumping around and like quickly
pivoting your aim or even like Bastion
and that kind of stuff
so it could be a case that you know
there's certain characters that it works
with you know maybe a part 1 0 to brawl
or or something like that but given the
nature of Apex relying way more heavily
on shooting than just your abilities I
expect that it's gonna be a novelty that
people move away from and generally will
either use the the onboard icons if
they're wild or kind of thing like a pro
controller if they're if they want to
so lost treasures goes live June 23rd
switch and cross player come in a fall
although I'm British so awesome all
right next up was the serious love you
next up the Sims kind steam I know they
just announced a new pack which released
a new pack very nice sentiment from The
Sims they are very in tune with that
community that was a very heartwarming
and heartfelt just kind of celebration I
think of their community there I mean
personally I have the Sims through
origin so doesn't really mean much for
people who already own the Sims but
hopefully this opens it up a little bit
to people who just want to play it on
Steam I don't really have much else to
say about the Sims I don't know oh do we
think the time is almost nigh for Sims 5
Michael I don't know I think I feel like
with the the live service style of games
that we're seeing as a not just the
trend but just like across the board
games are adopting that live service
thing Sims 4 seems like it's in a really
good place with expansions and added
content like I think it would almost be
a disservice that try to do a Sims 5
because there's so many people who are
invested in Sims 4 and like EA
themselves I've done so much work to
make that game not just inclusive but
just giving everyone something to do in
the game - that that kind of strikes
their fancy as well so you know props
The Sims for being that game where like
they said you know this isn't just the
games you know they get to live out
another life for themselves whether they
want to see themselves in the game or if
they want to be something else in that
game and just the wide swath of things
that mechanics and things to do in that
game that have come with all those
different expansions so now props The
Sims 4 that that kind of montage and the
stuff like I mean they didn't have a
massive thing to show off that was new
but you know doesn't have to be that and
I appreciate that yeah and you know they
led on to the announcement that a bunch
of other things are gonna come to steam
so we already had apex Sims title to
weigh out dead space
not one and two come on conquering
bastards and FIFA 21 town what do you
think the future of origins gonna look
like if they kind of just moving
everything back to steam I think or it
shouldn't really impact origin in a
major way I feel like there's enough
hooks within origin that make make it
valuable for people who still want to
use it whether that's discounts or early
access free games that kind of stuff
they won't be getting any of that
through Steam they just gain access to
the game I think it's only beneficial
for EA to make games like these they up
right now picking specific types of
games that are moving over and they're
games that have a longevity to them or
they're games that have been long so
after like it makes sense to put you
know a cnc remastered sims 4 and an apex
on there because they have massive
communities as is and by doing so they
only grow and time for two is a beloved
game so you know the who knows it could
be given like a shot in the arm and
multiplayer if they put it on that and
like way out for example is a it's a
great opportunity for people who may
have skipped it in on other platforms to
check it out especially given that hazel
has another game on the way and then you
know same for Dead Space 3 I think
unless I'm I'm forgetting like dead
space wanted to might already be on
Steam yeah so they think they were they
originally released on I have memories
of that because it's always in some sort
of discount deals promotion so I think
this is just completing the set to a
large degree but yeah FIFA as well like
it just makes sense to put them there I
don't think it has a negative impact on
on EA and origins on servers I think it
only serves to help them and giving more
people access to their franchises and
games is only beneficial for you and I
think as well maybe it'll serve as a
funnel to get more people to subscribe
to the vaults
yeah access so maybe that'll happen
you'll see an uptick there you mentioned
a way out there so we also saw a bunch
of EA originals
um I always I was loved like I was
looking forward to this section of VA
press conferences because it is nice to
see a juggernaut like ei take a chance
really on smaller and quirky and more
unique type games we've had sea of
solitude from them unraveled and so
there's this nice little cartoon
featuring a bunch of the developers that
they're working with they started off
with Joseph Aris we know that he tweeted
about it we were talking about it in the
pre-show so his new game from haze light
is it takes to baby make a thing go
right oh we both went to very different
directions it takes two to get to
different songs wait Michael what did
you think
okay thanks to know enough from y'all
let me add boy let's see
so spouses a tale of two parents is very
exciting for me I think that it's gonna
be a very fun game to play as Joseph
Farah says it's gonna blow your effing
mind so you know I'll take his word for
actually it's called it takes two like
Lucy said haha
I got jokes you know I'm saying but I
think that it's in line with him doing
co-op games so that part was kind of
expected now you know as it's funny
because Joseph Faris is so full of
himself I love it I love how much he
loves himself it's almost like you love
to hate him or you hate to love him but
you know props to him for being being
that and really going all in on that and
I'm surprised ei replayed his video game
or its appearance so that that was nice
to see I guess but in terms of like it
takes to it almost channels a little bit
more of the brothers vibe to it because
it has a little bit more familial in
terms of its themes and for as for as
into himself as he is I think that the
stories that are told in those games are
actually like pretty well grounded
obviously like haze light as he said
haze light is designed as a way to bring
together the the writers and
storytellers with the people who make or
like the programmers so that they have a
cohesive game where the
anacs are also a part of the narrative
and yeah that that's to say I'm also
excited for it and it's gonna tell oh
man if you got daddy issues or mommy
issues like I'm gonna be this might be a
game for us a child of divorced parents
a shout-out to divorce you don't say but
no let's not shout divorce please all
right childhood trauma out here and
that's the theme of the game too at
least from what's being communicated is
that you play as a character whose two
parents are arguing they're like in the
midst of a split and you know the main
character has like these two dolls that
are supposed to represent her parents
and then eventually it goes into this
more ethereal kind of surrealist 5 where
there's gonna be a lot of more co-op
gameplay mechanics so this is something
that I'm genuinely interested in because
not just because Joseph Aris and like
the games that he makes but you know I
think this is something that can really
much channel that sort of energy Tim
what about lust and random from Zoey
zoink games yeah I mean that game it
seems really interesting I love the idea
of taking random elements of a game and
kind of making it the core conceit of
the actual experience so the game was
actually announced a little while back I
was like 2019 that they originally
announced it but I I'm interested in
seeing how it goes like you said earlier
these games that the EA shows are
usually the stuff that is really
experimenting with and doing like going
out there with so this is kind of like
mechanically speaking a really unique
kind of experience amongst this table of
EA games and it's like referred to as
like a coming-of-age story and it's got
this interesting like Gothic backdrop
where it's kind of timber and esque so
like they talk about they mentioned it
being like a you take control of a young
girl who goes on this dangerous journey
through a world of like random things
and like you've got a companion
character called IC who's able to kind
of change change the outcome of random
events for you so I
really like to set up for it I'm really
interested to see how the mechanics come
together and how that randomization
manifests in gameplay mechanics and
ideas a lot of potential there I really
like what I'm seeing so far yeah
and then the final EA originals was from
final strike games rocket arena so I
think this one that kind of kid it
reminded me I think in style and tone of
the what was the game that was in the PS
5 and it was basically like rocket
League but oh yeah I feel bad but I
remember like the cartoony kind of vibe
that you get from it it looks like a lot
of fun I think there was something like
ten characters dynamic maps rockets each
character has a hundred levels of
progression I love that kind of stuff I
get really into it I'm a little
concerned that it's all rockets though
like I would like I mean it's very much
in keeping with the title of the game
but hmm I don't know it's gonna be
enough variety for me Michael
oh one thing I will say about it is that
I think some we got some information
beforehand about it and the one thing
that I do appreciate out appreciate
about its approach is its non violence
so everyone has rockets and stuff but
the core conceit is that you're supposed
to knock them out of the arena and you
know I appreciate games when they don't
rely on violence as a mechanism I mean
that's not to say that I don't play
violent video games like y'all about to
play less it was too late tonight so and
I'm so like apex legends like how I play
a bunch of first-person shooters and all
that but you know when when a studio or
developer tries to go for that that's
that that's that's pretty cool so I mean
maybe we'll see how the mechanics shake
out oh hi sushi yeah but anyway like a
rock and Reena like shouts out to y'all
for trying out trying that approach
appreciate that yeah I mean very big
splatoon vibes I guess you could say
from that too
the main meat I think of this press
conference I think we'll all agree star
wars squadrons so there's a little
interview in Fraser that even Fraser
he came from the mass spectrometer team
and we moved over to motive we got to
see some gameplay a lot of really really
cool features here that they revealed
like you could play the whole thing in
VR there's a little room that you can
chat to your like chat tactics with with
your team mates tam let's talk a little
bit about it what caught your eye I mean
I think it's just the entire thing was I
think they said a lot of the right
things there in terms of what people
want the tactical nature of it and the
different play styles that they
highlighted like you can do a all-out
attack you can try and focus on stealth
runs you can do like just big bombing
runs I love the that kind of style of
play that you everyone's got a favorite
kind of ship everyone's got a favorite
moment from the Star Wars franchise
especially the dogfighting sections
where it's like oh yeah I remember you
know the stealth run in this movie or
whatever maybe so I imagine there's a
lot of wish fulfillment happening in
this kind of enabling different styles
of play and the tactical nature of it
seems like they very they are playing
they're up which is important like it's
easy to just focus on like the the kind
of surface level replication of you know
a dog fighting game install was
environment in space but the longevity
comes from how much you can do within
that the strategies you can employ the
missions that you go on and it looks
like they've have enough open-ended
stuff in here that it will be repeatable
and real pre playable but on top of that
they've got that cool story which is
interesting I love the idea of two
pilots basically charting the course of
what happens in the world and you kind
of experiencing that through a
single-player story campaign yeah saying
all the right things looking the part
and showing off a lot of like depth
potential there
I think it's a strong start for this
game so far yeah and definitely Michael
what do you think
I think that everyone got what they
wanted from Star Wars squad squadrons an
in-depth look at the gameplay and like
it's it's cool because my expectations
were kind of like okay just adapt
battlefront twos flight for like a full
fledge game that's kind of what I said
in the pre-show but they went into depth
about how the team the different kind of
class mechanics work in like in actual
practice and that's a very important
thing to communicate when trying to sell
your game on this this concept right and
like having the different different
types of ships and complaints or yeah
the different fighters like showing how
they work was was really cool and also
the fact that they're incorporating a
single-player experience along with it
now it might be something like four or
five hour experience sort of like what
battlefront 2 offered but the fact that
it's part of the package is exciting
that seems to be some some pretty dope
characters we'll see how how that how
that shakes out but in terms of
characters like there's there's some
folks I want to know more of I want to
fight alongside things like that but in
terms of the multiplayer there's like a
traditional kind of I guess I think
there was like a death death match style
mode but they're there they also kind of
walked you through a sort of objective
base mode where you have several steps
within a match that you need to destroy
this ship you need to protect this your
squad needs to move in this fashion to
achieve achieve this objective
that's all exciting and also shouts not
to like the UI designers for this thing
because it's not like a traditional
style where you have all the numbers on
the side of your screen all the UI
elements are on your ship and I think
that they've only shown gameplay from
the cockpit perspective so I think
they've said before when they first
revealed it that this is gonna be a
first-person flight game and I don't
know if that was just like an emphasis
be and they would have different
perspective options but it seems like
that that is primarily what you're gonna
be working with and the fact that all of
your UI elements everything that you
need to know is represented on the
cockpit of the ship is pretty cool and
the fact that everything's gonna be in
VR I don't know the VR is going to be an
advantage
or a like a disadvantage when you're
actually playing but the fact that
they're going to the lengths to
incorporate the entire game in VR is
also very like that's exciting too so I
really feel like they're they're going
the extra mile to really make this feel
like a full-fledged Star Wars experience
yeah I was just gonna add yeah he's
actually updated their website to
include a little more content about
what's going to be included in the game
specifically the location so if you're a
match doll what's funny honestly where
you're going you can check that out it's
got lucky Evan prime SLS and the theory
dockyards and see subo zaevion abyss and
Gallatin and there's like screenshots of
each one along with a little description
and there's there's like a lot of
gameplay overview stuff on the storm
squadron website so a lot of info they
are very much dumping out there right
now which is great news for people who
are excited about this so a little peek
behind the curtain of how we run the
show as the press conference is going on
we write what the games are and then we
write a little our names next to it
about who's interested in talking about
like taking point on that subject matter
next up is Madden apparently I'm taking
the song favorite how do you feel about
who's your favorite Madden I'd have to
say mr. Madden
that's the margin so let's use this also
as a segue to talk about EA's next-gen
efforts yeah as you can see right here
next-gen a world premiere we got to see
this trailer of I guess just like EA
Sports you know saying yep next-gen is
coming we're working on it we're gonna
see bits of FIFA here in there bits of
Madden and then in that full next-gen
cheat next in next-gen T's you get to
see some of the concepts that they're
working on from specific Studios like
criterion Bioware and dice so let's talk
through all of the above Michael what do
you make of the Sports announced
we you know did that pique your interest
or was it the other next-gen tees that
really got to you I like sports all
right so we got two British folks on
here who only know football as the footy
sport where you kick a ball around but
you know as an American I need to
represent real football
so Madden 21 you know I'm actually a
little disappointed because I was
expecting more details on Madden 21 man
it's it's cool to see like all the March
axes taking a taking a tick-tock on his
own phone and putting up on the EA slow
play livestream that's cool shot the
Lamar Jackson oh my god does one of the
greatest seasons I've ever watched or
saw highlights of because I'm on an NFL
boycott but anyway shots of Lamar
Jackson he's a cover athlete and for me
though I wanted to get into more depth
of the Madden 21 mechanics because
they're doing it seems like they're
trying to do some more interesting
things with how that game is played but
overall I think that badly see I needed
to say something about next-gen and it's
pretty easy to like package that with
sports because you know damn well like
the sports games are gonna come to
next-gen things like that but we're
getting closer and closer to these
console releases I want a little bit
more details I know that ongoing games
such as apex you know I asked respawn
about what their plans are they had
nothing to share and there wasn't really
any like okay here's our next gen game
that we're going all-in with was I want
to see a little bit more of that but you
know not much not much else to make out
of it I think yeah I was actually kind
of surprised given how much sports
usually take a lot of time up in ES
press conference obviously FIFA Madden
they are their bread and butter when it
comes to raking in those micro
transactions they make so much money
every year they have such a huge
audience who buys you know the new
installment every year I was very
surprised that we didn't see more
they're kind of slowly releasing details
about FIFA gonna come to steam but
nothing on this year's installments just
yet maybe what they I mean what they
usually do is like they kind of leave it
to maybe be closer to Gamescom time that
is still happening so maybe maybe that's
what they're just doing they're just
kind of putting it out there you know
and then we'll get to see all the next
gens
maybe later on in the summer Sam what
did you make of it yeah I think that's
pretty much what I FIFA and Madden and
you know other sports I oh they're so
big that I think they would need their
own breathing room and the level of
nuance and depth that you need to go to
really show why you know they need to
justify a new new version of a game each
time so whether that's you know we've
got advanced new grass-blade physics
like they need to really get into the
granular detail to show the people who
love these games what's new like in our
crowd physics or crowd you know
rendering or all physics whatever it may
be and it's not great for those people
it's not great an experience for them to
just rush through it and I feel like
that would also eat up a lot of time and
then for everyone who's not there for
the sports they don't want 30 minutes of
how a ball is bouncing around a field so
I feel like the right call for them is
to kind of make sure that they're
teasing that stuff and then breaking it
out so it has this breathing room and
they can get you know various footballer
follows back to talk about at length and
get the developers to in to explain
Atlanta why what's going on behind the
scenes to explain how next-gen works
with these four styles I mean like the
FIFA stuff is important the Madden stuff
is important but like I think there's
still other things that need to kind of
like be touched upon as well as part of
this slate like the UFC I don't know if
that's still happening and NHL and that
kind of stuff so I imagine there's going
to be a drip-feed of big like me info
drops on the sports titles individually
over the next few months and like you
said games comes usually a big one for
FIFA so perhaps we'll see a little more
of that in a few weeks we also got that
next-gen tees so it's very specific
Studios that were mentioned you know
criterion a day what are they working on
the brand new Need for Speed
yes I need for speed is the next game
from criterion they officially said that
they're ending support for the current
need for speed so they can you know
shift over to that stuff I was in the
news a couple weeks back makes a lot of
sense the studio's been kind of like
helping out on racing tails and also
supporting Star Wars titles but they are
now custodians of
for speed a wholesaler I believe and so
that's exciting they make great games
they make great racing games hopefully
they can get Need for Speed back on some
sort of track or road I don't know how
that works
I wonder what's gonna become a ghost
games then you didn't need to speed a
few years ago who knows ghosted Bioware
got mentions this was the only mention
of Bioware in this whole press
conference
Geoff Grubb has been tweeting a lot
about you know leaks and stuff over the
summer he's mentioned he's kind of done
like an update tweet he said battlefield
six is gonna be modern UFC is coming he
is gonna make a golf game on its own
again Battlefield Bad Company remastered
Gork and Mass Effect 3 mass is coming
this year Bioware already said it's
working on anthem 2.0 and Dragon Age 4
so that's the update from I'm not gonna
say that his inside a knowledge if it is
inside a knowledge is correct but this
is what is going around on line right
now that T's that we got there from
Bioware definitely look like Dragon Age
to me they mentioned building your
fantasy worlds I assume that's
definitely Dragon Age we know they're
working on it yeah oh Michael what do
you think about what you know man
it's I think it's fair to say that
Bioware fans are we can say we're
disappointed right but that doesn't like
that we don't mean any ill-will when we
say that it's just like okay we're like
we're ready to see what y'all got maybe
they're not ready that's fine but I said
in the pre-show that like they don't
have to show Dragon Age for gameplay but
maybe an update on the state of the game
some ideas that they have going maybe
like a short little teaser trailer who
didn't even really get that so you know
I don't want to complain but it was a
little disappointing to get no Dragon
Age 4 news because this is in lieu of
III also so yeah those little
disappointing but a play like we keep
saying that the mass spec remasters
where they at where they at
yeah but I mean yeah oh sorry
caramel Michael okay oh you don't like
yes okay yielded I was so sorry I
thought you still had like one more
thing I just want to make sure everyone
gets that time time you can talk to
about bio way too but what else did you
make of that that's showing from DICE it
was kind of strange it was like a third
person tumbling through the air you had
I don't know you were knocking over
blocks what was that about
yeah I mean firstly the lack of bio way
is upsetting to me and I feel personally
slighted because I'm a gamer online so
that's how I behave but these other kind
of like weird new kind of tech thing
that they were showing like it's super
early I'm not sure what that was even so
but like it's really hard to get an
indication of what that game could be it
reminded me of remember that ps3 launch
title pain where you just like flung a
dude things and allowed it allowed like
bad things to happen to him but it looks
like this is just them saying like hey
we're working on an engine we've got
something exciting that dude falling
through the air sure did look like a
bounty hunter but you know who knows
that could be a Star Wars thing it could
be something else entirely but like the
jetpack vibe that he had I was like
maybe maybe like an open-world bounty
hunter game who knows but yeah it's too
early to say what it could be but it's
just in saying hey we're working on next
gen technology so please be excited not
much to gather from it but good luck to
them basically alright and let's end on
the surprise reveal the just one more
thing a new skate game hey your plea
whoa I told you Bernie Sanders alone in
a skate park doing an ollie on his own
finally is happy we once again asked for
skating for and we got ok before we got
we got skate they didn't say skate for
they said skate is back which is
interesting so if it turns out to be a
remaster
sure why not we'll take anything at this
point well I do wonder whether it's a
full sequel of it is a remaster because
if it's a remaster that's probably a way
to hedge your bet slightly yeah has
traditionally not shown a lot of faith
in the skating genre especially for
video games I imagine they're like
peeking through the window of steam and
seeing like skater Excel and everything
else kind of like coming out and being
like everyone's making skate games we've
got this one game that people will not
stop spamming hashtags about maybe we
can remake one of the previous games in
the franchise or if they are bold enough
to put a whole new skate game in there I
respect it I think the important thing
is like from the fanbases perspective
they're happy either way like we've got
something to do escape Michael your big
skate fan compass make you feel sure it
made me feel a lot of things all right I
but now the tam has mentioned it you
know they didn't explicitly say skate
for but that's what everyone's thinking
I you know to be to be honest though
alike I don't think remastering the
skate games would be I don't think that
that's the route that most people want
because like if you think about it like
even though skate three hat it's been
ten years since skate 3 but if you go
back and replay that game it holds up
really well I don't really think that
game needs a remaster it just it it
already feels really good or it feels
good still to play but assuring in skate
the series into a next generation
because like they didn't say anything
definitive so it's probably always out
2021 probably but you know if they're
gonna if that's what they're gonna end
on and you know make a statement about
the thing that people have been
clamoring for for multiple years it
would have to be a full-on sequel or
next-gen game for skate but you know
there we didn't get any gameplay we
didn't get any like it's teaser trailer
they just kind of said all skates back
which is you know what that's that's
enough for me that that gives us hope
and it gives me hope to see that like
that they understand what the like fans
are that fans want so whenever we do get
to see gameplay or a trailer or more
details on it I do have faith that it
will be the thing that everyone
wants whether it's skate for or skate
renamed with whatever subtitle but yeah
I'm ready you know thps1 and to remaster
comments gator excels out there or it's
coming out there I'm ready for a
real-deal kickflips bro let's go man
all right over Altima what did you think
of EA play 2020 no Mass Effect no Dragon
Age 1 out of 10 Wow
damn cutting Michael spicy um it was it
wasn't that hype you know it wasn't like
terribly exciting but you know I'm
excited for the things they showed I'm
excited that we got to see Greg Miller
out there fresh haircut you know I'm
saying sure sure yeah homeboys looking
real nice so show us up to him Lucy tell
them that I'm a big fan of his haircut
it was nice but you know good son there
are some things that are better dope I
think them going all in with Star Wars
squadrons was was a good call mentioning
skateboard was a good call
of course like like tam said today no
mass effect no dragon age so I'm nice
obviously to out of time no I'm just
kidding was good but it was it was it
was decent okay yeah I mean I think the
curse that EA is always gonna have now
is you know they've given in they've
relinquished and done the scape whatever
the new scape is I'm just gonna say
skate for for the purposes of this
analogy but you know now every time
they're gonna do something it's gonna be
whereas Mass Effect where's Dragon Age
and it's a blessing and a curse because
you've got a very passionate fan base
but it kind of means that everything
else is drowned out by those voices a
little bit I'm of the opinion like that
conference was kind of a nice
all-rounder it didn't have as many like
big huge announcements as I would have
liked but getting to see more of Star
Wars getting my apex news I love the way
they're continuing to support that front
well franchise so to speak it's within
titanfall world the way they're
supporting that game and giving it like
to shine because if you think about the
way it was announced it was very much
BAM
we've done this we have you know it's
out now so I'm loving it spotlight
I'm gonna be one of those people who
once mass effect but I can wait for it
all right oh it looks great yep that was
looks great
yeah a Star Wars hashtag skate skate for
squeeze squirt oh let's go star we'll
skaters
let's go Darth Maul is in Tony Hawk's
Pro Skater come on let's go
look the cross that has happened let's
make it happen again Michael Oh Tom
thank you so much for joining me today
and thank you everyone who's been in the
chat watching along with us GameSpot has
all the huge announcements from this
summer as part of our play for all which
is a mix of all the big kind of
announcements all the big gaming stuff
that you would expect from three as well
as daily charity streams raising money
for black lives matter as well as Direct
Relief and their Cove in nineteen relief
efforts so please donate come join us on
a stream one of these days got some
great guests lined up we've got last
podcast on the left tomorrow we've got
Joe seizure from Fire Emblem three
houses a lot of other fun stuff planned
thanks again for joining us we'll see
you next time peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]